des enfants qui font la guerre ou
presque
il ne risque pas grand chose si ce n'est
une balle de peinture en paintball deux
équipes s'affrontent sur un terrain et
pour survivre il ne faut pas se faire
toucher
bah je regardais jeudi les îles leur
tire dessus
on en a tué quatre mon frère 2 et après
c'est on a gagné on est venu faire cette
activité en famille passer un bon moment
les enfants aiment un peu les sports un
peu extrêmes donc on en profite
une activité proposée exceptionnellement
sur l'île de loisirs pour ces journées
portes ouvertes les visiteurs ont pu se
lancer d'autres défis comme le football
ou l'équitation
un événement pour lancer la saison avec
l'arrivée des beaux jours
il ya encore trop de personnes qui ne
connaissent pas ce havre de paix cela
ouvre des espaces verts donc voilà c'est
ça l'objectif principal c'est de faire
découvrir l'île de loisirs et toutes les
activités qui s'y pratiquent le panel
d'activités est très très très complet
et pour reprendre la formule bien connue
de 7 à 77 ans mais bien au-delà
face au succès de ce week end le
paintball devraient être ajoutés au
catalogue d'activités chaque année six à
sept cent mille visiteurs sont
accueillis sur les 620 hectares de l'île